[Music]
now these domestic goddesses are gonna
decorate their fairy cakes let the
imagination go and don't forget we're
selling these it's great decoration that
sells a cupcake put the glitter on at
the end otherwise you're gonna be going
back looking like a bunch of fairies
coated in glitter designs range from
disastrous nozzles got to go inside the
bag to the delectable and a damn ride
dodgy nice what's the theme that's fine
when you are way on crap we're not on
crack now so we don't hop in space the
glittery should be sprinkled lightly you
know I said the runs on top of that one
I am NOT gonna sell that yeah
next to that let me tell you what which
one would you buy thank you very much
but one burglar has done a lovely little
job did you do that did you did he do it
that's nice yeah there's not too bad at
all
beautiful okay no no no no not that one
yourself we're selling them all stop no
no no we're gonna sell them back in the
cupcake marketing department the
ruthless criminals can't resist a little
bit of glitter
confident cupcakes post-up designed by a
test for over there you know we you know
promoted your name in it so we could
sell more right you know real taste of
prison it's like the colors the convicts
cupcake shop is popping up just outside
a wing you like for prints
selling them on my hustlers Anthony
Kelly and test for Jones
[Music]
[Music]
they can start earning some legit cash
[Music]
[Music]
well then do you tell the pan yeah I'm
watching you like a hawk damn right came
over the [ __ ] Kitty box let me tell
you you see that's going to disappear so
that's 49 quid we've taken 20 of which
is profit this little beginning of
something pretty major because I can
turn forty quid into four grand a week
it's gonna take a lot of sweat yeah pain
yeah
now I'm gonna think long and hard about
who from this group will make my final
twelve are you scared of hard work I'm
not scared at all
I've done it in the past and I'm mainly
szustak I think it depends on what I'm
doing big question is when was the last
time you worked 60 hours in a week
straight what yeah 20 years ago I got
dealt a dysfunctional cars
my little brother became a heroin addict
and my father became an alcoholic
Flores
[Music]